A [inaudible] Jad here.
This is WNYC's radio lab.
Prior to the station Id we were listening to a conversation between two Roberts,
Robert Number one is right here with me,
Mr Krulwich [inaudible] and Robert too is a what we'll hear from him morning
moment. Robert's Polski, Stanford University professor.
The topic of that conversation and of our show is stress,
stress then and stress. Now
as we heard stress then would count is something like being chased across the
Savanna by a saber tooth tiger stress now standing in the wrong line at the
supermarket.
Very different kinds of stress separated by thousands of years of human
experience,
but to the body they are the same and too many false tiger alerts will make you
sick. Now that right there, the connection between stress and sickness,
how that connection was made is an interesting story which involves lots of
people. Let's start with one Dr. Paul j Roshan,
president of the American Institute of stress and I've been involved in stress
research for well over 50 years and it was around 50 years ago that Dr. Rush and
a few colleagues meet an interesting discovery.
They took a bunch of rodents and did some well,
not so nice things to them like sewing back the eyelids of mice and shining
lights in their eyes and definitely noises. When we put them on treadmills,
I left them out on the roof of the medical school in the cold wintery Canadian
blizzards.
We throw the animals into water so they would have to constantly swim.
You would do that for hours or days until they were too weak and then measure
their hormonal secretion.
Anything that would be a severely noxious threat or challenge.
If there's any justice in the world,
this guy's going to rat hell is going to be some rodent named Alice stitching
his eyeballs, but let's go on. But in the name of science,
what Russian company noticed is that every different type of cruel torture
technique they did to these poor runs resulted in the same outcome.
They got sick and sick in the same way, sort of a flu like symptoms.
Furthermore,
we quickly learned that it wasn't necessary to do these horrible things to get
almost the same effect.
Now they could get the same effect by merely frustrating the rats,
put their food out and then before the Ras get it taken away,
then put it out again. Then Ooh, thought you had it. Take it away again.
Just by doing that over and over,
that would make some of the rats and some of them could cope and right. The Cup.
Yeah. Well, this is Robert. Supposedly the professors has been helping us along,
says that human beings break down and pretty much the same categories.
There are some people who can be challenged by all the daily experiences and
they just kind of glide through it and there are other people like you who get
furious. Just furious. Key thing really is the hostility.
It's the hostility
and it's a particular style that may seem very familiar to our New York
metropolitan area listening ship. And I see this as a native New Yorker,
but it's the style called toxic hostility where just everything in the world
around you confirmed they're out to get you.
They're out to get you preferentially.
Every elevator door that closes before you get there is proof.
The person inside who could've stopped it but chose not to is out to stab you in
the back. And this is a really, really hostile world out there.
And this is the way of life. This is two which everyone says it is. It's true.
That is how the world is. Um, and some people have this,
it DIYers sort of in a dire sort of way.
And I suppose his point is that the people who do have it in a dire sort of way,
you get sick. Yeah. There's a,
a kind of anger and style that is so bad for your nervous system that's like
worse than smoking. I mean, literally with me,
this is what is famously called type a behavior.
Type A was first described by these two cardiologists, Friedman and Rosenman.
That's my Friedman Ray Rosamund and they came up with this idea in the 1950s
their original version was your hostel time pressured and patient low self
esteem, joy, less striving.
All you live for is to check things off your to do list and you know,
this is what they were originally saying greatly increases your risk of heart
disease and cardiologists hated these guys for this simple reason.
Your son like Ozzie and Harriet Eisenhower era cardiologist and all,
you think about his like heart valves and blood lithics and here's these guys
saying no,
you got to sit down your patients and talk to them and find out if they've
picked the wrong line in the supermarket.
Did they go berserk at that point and it took decades for it to become clear
that this really is for real. Yeah.
[inaudible]
well,
here are two cardiologists proposing that you are more likely to get a heart
attack,
not based on the size of your veins or whatever's passing through your butt,
but on the kind of guy or kind of gal you are. Exactly.
How did they come to this peculiar insight? Okay, this is,
this is where this great story comes from and I wouldn't have believed it except
it was told to me by Friedman himself and appropriately sheepishly.
Um, so this was back in the 50s,
and they've got this cardiology practice and everything's going great,
except apparently they had this one problem which they were having to spend a
fortune reupholstering the arm chairs in their office, in the,
in the office, in their waiting room. What's this about?
They had no idea that they paid no attention to it.
It's part of the overhead thing at this upholstery who comes every month.
It's got to fix a couple of chairs every month. Every month. Yeah.
So one month you pollster is out on vacation, replacement upholstery comes in,
takes one look at the chairs and discovers type a personality,
presenting great moments in will. Never come up post spreads.
He says, what the Hell was wrong with your patients? Nobody wears ax.
Here's this way and the guys absolutely right.
They still have one chair which I hope they are going to give to the Smithsonian
and what it is is the front two inches of the seat Christian and the front two
inches of the armrests are totally shredded and the rest of the chairs fine. Mm
[inaudible]
I do. My shredded is like ripped. That's where the tears are.
It's not evenly distributed and their nails and do it or something.
Well basically what you've got there is the type a profile.
The person literally sitting on the edge of their seat and squirming and fussing
with the arm chairs and clawing and none of this were on the chair distributed
over the entire budget range of weight, displacement of it.
People are sitting there on the edge of their seats.
So the upholsterer says to the cardiologist,
there's something wrong with the people in your waiting room. Exactly.
[inaudible]
and what's supposed to happen at this point?
This is supposed to be this epiphanal moment and one of these winds up in the
textbooks.
If like midnight conferences between upholsterers and cardiologists or like they
do these huge surveys in young, idealistic,
upholsters sweep across America and discover, you know,
you don't see chairs like these and a podiatrists office owning the cardiac.
That's what's supposed to happen. Here's where Friedman says,
get this guy out of my face. I need to see patients. I'm this important guy.
Give him his damn check. He was to type Adal, listen to the guard.
So he threw the balls to her out. He but give him this check,
get them Outta here. In five years later,
they're doing these studies with these psychologists and out pops the type a
profile and they say, oh my God, the upholster he was right. To this day,
they have no idea who the man was.
And I'm willing to bet that like there's this 95 year old upholster guy in some
bar in San Francisco right now who's droning on about how he discovered type a
personality and it's absolutely true.
[inaudible]
listen what search have yet to reveal the identity of that replenishment uphold.
Okay.
This story has been brought to you by the American upholstery association
dedicated to find clock fine furniture under healthier America.
My name is Charles Young and I do a pulse rate,
which you're working on here. Well, I'm doing a rocker.
It's a nice gesture actually. It just,
they water seed all the way down to the wood.
Sometime the things are so bad that they said,
oh please cover it before you take it.
Cause I don't want people in the building know how bad my furniture room.
But I'm saying, how could you live like this in your own house? It's a mess.
It's a mess. We couldn't find the guy, the Taipei guy.
But in the process of looking, you
ran across Charles Young and in this messy stressful world,
his lower east side studio is a window onto calmer times.
A long time ago there was um,
Straw inside of the dual stuff. Hold on from the SIF.
So stuff,
this is a photograph of an old chair like was made about a hundred years ago.
I don't remember if you can see that, but there's Straw inside there.
All stuff is a class to it and you don't mind working on it. The new stuff
is not that big and little stuff is all badly put together,
stapled together so we can't fix it.
Oh,
because everything we do with throw away and go buy a new,
okay.
It's not the glamorous job in the world, but it's a job.
Yeah.
People don't want to learn how to do a pulse for it.
It's a dying art,
so I don't know what they gonna do.
[inaudible]
do you want to know about upholstery?
Visit Charles Young owner of CYA upholstery company on the lower east side.
He's been doing it for decades.
My best customers are adults and they chew up people far too,
which is absolutely one. Charlie spoke with producer Ellen Horn.
You've got to go Chad here with Robert Krulwich.
Today on radio lab. We are looking at stress,
the effects of stress on chairs and on us
to get back to our bodies for just a second.
Remember before we said that when you get scared and you're going to make a
presentation,
your mouth goes dry because your digestive system is beginning to shut down.
It's also true that if you're very, very nervous that you wouldn't know this.
You stop growing
[inaudible]
and this is even for a very little bit of time, a short spurt of panic.
We'll create a short spurt of nun growth that's on one end.
But just professor Robertson [inaudible] supposedly expose someone to a lot of
continuing stress and add an extreme.
You got one of the truly bizarre outposts in medicine.
This disease of kids who stopped growing for reasons of psychological stress,
meaning they are so nervous about whatever it is that their system doesn't is
spends all the time pumping and palpitating and doing all this again,
no growing saying grow tomorrow, grow tomorrow, tomorrow.
This has no time for it. And it's well documented. This is not Ooh,
fourth grade teacher who is mean and yells at the kids.
This is like nightmare police and the social workers breaking down the door of
the apartment, sort of nightmare stuff. Um, and amazingly,
you get the kids out of those settings and often they will start growing again.
Okay.
So you read up a lot about this and there's this weird pattern I had noted in a
lot of these unreadable chapters,
which is they would make reference to Peter Pan
[inaudible].
They would start with a quote from Peter Pan or some snide comments about
Tinkerbell. And I'd seen this for years. I had no idea what this was about.
To one day I finally found the next
shit,
eight year old kid growing up in Victorian England.
One day he sees his beloved 12 year old brother killed in front of them.
Horrible accident. This destroys the family.
And this was the mother's favorite child who dies,
takes to her bed in this Victorian swoon for the next 10 years.
Totally ignoring this child, growing up in this emotional isolation,
these horrible scenes.
The boy comes in with a tray of food for his mother and she's going on, oh,
David David, is that you, David? If you come to me, David, the dead son.
So the second has left standing in the door doors like, Gee, it's only me.
It's me. It's me. Sorry, I'm not David. Sorry, I'm not David. Sorry.
It wasn't me. Instead of him.
Only thing she apparently ever spoke to him about was this crazy idea she
grabbed on to, which was if David had to die, at least he was still a boy.
He's not one of these boys who grows up and doesn't need his mother anymore.
He'll always be my perfect little boy cause he didn't grow up.
He didn't grow up in to grow up.
This kid hears this with a vengeance and stops growing. At that point,
he lives to be 60 years old, under five foot tall, unconsummated marriage,
complete maturational arrested. He hit puberty. He did.
He grew facial hair. Um,
but most indications are not a whole lot of other secondary sexual
characteristics. And as an adult,
this was the author of the much beloved children's classic Peter Pan.
This was Jim Berry, the guy who wrote Peter Pan, who was a very,
very troubled man who among other things just endlessly turned out plays and
novels and whatevers about boys and Diane come back as ghosts and marry their
mothers and all sorts of adipose stuff like that.
Sadomasochistic fantasy stuff with the little boys. All,
all through his writings, his private writings. This was a very,
very troubled man who did not deal very well with the consequences of this for
the rest of his life.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
coming up the therapeutic benefits of screaming naeing and beating the crap out
of someone.